um
i
am going to briefly give you an overview
of some recent developments on our team
that our team has been working on and
what we have been implementing also on
our platform and as training and i'm
sure that mohit will try and figure out
his slides
so that he can kind of pick it up from
there
so briefly to get started um just one
second i need to um
finalize just one thing okay there we go
so um
let me share my screen
i have a few exciting things that i want
to share with you today
and those
include
i'll start from uh kind of the major
areas where our team is focused and uh
over the past several years now we have
been working with a variety of partners
and research collaborators and really
trying to connect education
with self-service tools or a platform
that we've been building for big data
analysis
as well as supporting different research
projects with services
and our goal is really to help translate
bioinformatics research to applications
and we do so in several different areas
so one of them is oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience and biotechnology
and so what we
want to share with you today are some of
the ways that you can learn about some
of these topics as a student
potentially as a researcher or as a
faculty member you can think of this as
an opportunity to also take some of the
resources that we've developed and use
them in your training
when you want to supplement your
curriculum with some hands-on practical
exercises that anyone without any
technical background can leverage
but also think of it as an opportunity
to
leverage the big data that is being
collected in all of these domains and
apply some of these tools to analyze
such data develop hypotheses potentially
utilize some of these methods in your
actual research
so what are some of those directions in
in these domains
in each one of these domains
we are looking at really an explosion of
different types of data such as genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics metagenomics
many other types of data that
essentially speak about biological
phenomena at very
detailed
molecular
kind of level right so
as a result of that there is a challenge
to process
analyze and integrate such data
in a meaningful way and when i say
meaningful way what i really mean is to
be able to
uh in a in an accurate way identify and
differentiate between signal and noise
that's challenge number one
and then challenge number two connect
the dots in this complex puzzle
to a biological phenomena or a signal
that we can interpret biologically
and so to do that a variety of methods
in all of these different types of data
have to be uh have to be easy to use
have to be accessible they have to be
understood and that's where the training
comes in but also in many cases they
still require a lot of time and that's
where our team can help and assist
either by mentoring
or by actually providing those services
and so i'll talk a little bit about how
we're doing that and briefly describe
some of the tools that you can even try
today
so what primarily i will be talking
about today is not the training
component i will leave that for mohit to
add on at the end of my presentation but
i will actually speak about some of the
tools that we use ourselves and some of
the tools that you can also leverage in
those kinds of research
domains and how they practically address
some of the bigger challenges in each
one of these domains
so we've been working with the tower
bioinformatics research center
a center out of israel
at the university of haifa in israel
that has been developing a comprehensive
platform that allows anyone without the
technical background so a biologist or
somebody coming from a life science
background to leverage these big data
tools to be able to
process analyze visualize and integrate
a lot of these types of omics data and
so some of the tools that i'll speak
about today are commonly used but i'll
speak about specific areas of
application where they can make a big
difference
but before i jump into those topics i
will briefly give you an overview of
what this platform is and how you can
use it today just to understand what
this really is
so uh to kind of learn about the
platform and take a look at it i want
you to please follow me on this link
server dot t dash dial
info
so this is a platform
that again you can register for free
the free registration is going to give
you demo access
to a lot of the tools that i will be
describing today and you'll be actually
able to try some of them in the context
of these
project examples some of the project
examples i will also mention
so once you are in this uh let me just
make this a little bit bigger
okay once you are here you will be able
to see that everything is separated into
several different sections
these sections are by data type or by
application you will also see some of
the newer sections that have been added
recently and so these are some of the
sections that i will be talking about
such as single cell analysis
and others so once you're here each one
of these sections represents a whole
section of methods that are organized
into a pipeline builder and this
pipeline builder is connected to some of
the training that we offer on our omits
logic portal so when you go through the
training you'll be able to use these
tools in a practical way when you use
them for research you will be given much
more access to uh data storage and
management capabilities and then also we
offer other types of use cases for this
platform so the basic idea
of each one of these sections is to
offer a pipeline builder and this
pipeline builder can be found
as a demo
based on a previously analyzed data set
or a project the demo project so the way
you would go into a demo is you would
click on this drop-down and then in one
of these you will find a pre-loaded data
set with a prepared step-by-step
pipeline builder tutorial
that results in an understanding of
inputs and outputs of each one of the
steps
but the platform is really built to
facilitate a streamlined research
process
organized around these different types
of omics data
where in each type of omics data you
would get the output that is already
structured and prepared for downstream
analysis
so that later on
you can use it to
visualize analyze and into integrate
some of the data sets and so as you can
see here you can both learn as well as
translate that understanding into an
actual research project
now what this does in terms of students
students that want to get into
bioinformatics bioinformatics when
people mention bioinformatics means so
many different things from very basic
things like learning how to search
properly on ncbi databases to a little
bit more advanced things like maybe
learning how to
analyze multiple sequence alignment data
on short sequences and all the way to
big data and so that is really where
what
what i'm going to be sharing today is
geared towards right how this these
kinds of tools can help simplify
processing and analysis and integration
of large data sets
now in each one of these sections you
will find that they are organized by
logical steps or logical
kind of
meaningful
methods
organized into groups
that mean something right and so the
logic is explained in several different
ways you can see it in pop-ups you can
also see that each step is color-coded
and because it is color-coded you tend
to remember
exactly what each step means
and finally at the end it produces an a
reproducible workflow so either way
where you stay on the platform when you
use the platform you remember what steps
you took or when you want to develop
your own pipeline you understand which
method falls under which group and you
can design your pipeline in a logical
way
in addition to that
we also offer different types of updated
visualization
options that we have recently been
working to update and those include
standard visualizations like jbrowse2
different types of interactive
visualizations like you can see the pca
on plotly as well as custom things that
we develop for specific projects that
seek to integrate complex data sets
together and provide a researcher with
an opportunity to explore their data
without having to deal with the
complexities of multiple sources of
information in several different formats
now when we think of this as a way to
design a research experience we can
really think about as a
as an application of some of these
and yes sarah
you can
access the codes or scripts behind these
pipelines they are provided in the
output so if you have a research account
some of the methods that are written in
r for example you can directly download
the scripts at the end
or
what we do in the training is we
actually go from these logical pipelines
into the actual methods that are used
and kind of go step by step into the
things that you can do to extract this
kind of information so that's what i
will be talking about today
so the way to do this is really to think
about bioinformatics as a component
of
the uh of the project of the biological
question that is being asked
uh so you know in many cases when we
think of methods like varian calling or
maybe uh you know non-metric
dimensionality scaling
we can learn about these methods but
unless we see
how they are applied in the context of a
real biological question to answer that
question it is difficult for us to
appreciate why the technical details
play such a major role in what we are
trying to do and so to design an
experience for those who are learning
bioinformatics to appreciate some of the
technical detail and to be motivated to
learn how to use these methods and
proper appropriately we have designed
some of these tutorials around different
types of projects as you can see here
cancer
biotechnology infectious diseases and
others and so what i wanted to do today
is briefly speak about three
applications in
metagenomics
single cell rna-seq
and kovitz surveillance because some of
these have really been seeing a major
interest from a community of different
researchers and so i want to talk about
some of the challenges and opportunities
in these types of applications so that
you can appreciate kind of how and why
it's important to learn some of these
tools and methods
uh so a single cell rna-seq
i'll start with this uh is an area that
has gone from kind of a very basic
research application where primarily
people were interested to understand
uh different cell types by annotation
to
more and more of a practical application
where we are now even seeing multi-omics
integration at the single cell but
importantly there is more integration
also with phenotype for example spatial
rna-seq
and the basis of being able to use some
of these kinds of advanced methods to
really drive translational research is
really understanding the logic behind
some of the ways that we process such
data and we are able to uh address some
of the technical challenges with the
type of data that we have
so let's first talk about processing
single cell rna-seq data
which tends to be a fairly
automated process
but at the same time it is a critical
step that helps us address a lot of the
technical variation at the beginning of
this
process so that our data is more
reliable when we do the downstream
annotation and visualization
so one of the major challenges uh is
multiple types of sequencing data
i mean 10x genomics has been recently
kind of become the standard but there
are still many other different methods
as well and one of the challenges is
here to address the artifacts
and so what we have done on the platform
is we have prepared a number of tools
that one can use to be able to process
different types of data with different
types of comparable methods and as you
know in bioinformatics a lot of the
challenges are being addressed by
looking at simultaneously running
several different pipelines and
comparing the results and so here this
is really their approach to
make sure that the data has passed the
quality control
has been addressed uh
at the batch and artifact
level and then also we have a very
specific output that we can evaluate for
how useful this is to do the downstream
analysis so this is challenge number one
and for anyone that has run these
pipelines you know that just putting
together a single pipeline can take
significant time running multiple
pipelines to compare them in parallel is
something that really becomes a huge
challenge and so having an interface
that has a consistency and a
reproducibility to it really allows you
to run through that step of qc
prepare your data in a reliable way and
know that it is something that you can
reproduce yourself
the downstream analysis also is a
challenge because when we have these
tables prepared the matrices
we now want to analyze the data by
comparing for example different clusters
different groups of samples to each
other
and really know that our outputs such as
differential gene expression outputs or
clustering annotation is a reliable
outcome and so here we've designed a
pipeline around silrat
and and producing
the integrated matrix so that we can
produce clustering and downstream
analysis and the important part here is
that we have
as you probably all know
seen many researchers struggle with some
of the basic challenges of civil rights
and and and these standard processing
tools uh for example in anchoring right
knowing how to normalize and harmonize
your data with harmony with anchoring
and so right with other tools like
monocle how to really validate some of
the cluster annotation there are many
different tools do you go about it
manually do you take some existing
package from r so those are some of the
questions that really
could be addressed in using such a
pipeline
now to the point that sarah was asking
how can you go from running a pipeline
like this to actually being able to
understand what goes in to every single
step and how do you use it
in our training we have a training
program called single cell
bulk and single cell rna-seq
and in that training that's exactly what
we do we go through the pipeline
we take some projects we see the inputs
and outputs and then we go into the
coding part for those that are
interested to really reproduce each step
using our
and trying to understand what are the
specific details that go into every step
that you need to master and kind of
learn so we provide you with a github
notebook that notebook you can rerun you
can change you can change the input and
the output of the data of course with
the limitations of the huge amounts of
data that are out there many of which
are too large to process uh in some of
these online environments
sorry on the environment on your
computer and so you have to rely on the
cloud
to really kind of effectively run some
of these pipelines but that's exactly
the objective and obviously
understanding how these objectives fit
into the specific projects is a critical
step because not only do you understand
the technical component but you can
apply it to address a specific research
question and see how people that
specialize in this domain can really be
able to do that
and as a result of this training and
developing these pipelines we've now
worked with multiple researchers at
louisiana state university and across
the lbrm network
georgetown university and ucsf to
support many of these research studies
that are trying to integrate the more
advanced methods like spatial
transcriptomics and integrate single
cell rna-seq data with bulk rna-seq for
example so really if you have any
specific questions about single cell
different methods
different types of projects i do
encourage you to reach out to us
our team here on the call can really
schedule a time to discuss with you how
your specific challenge or your interest
could be addressed using some of these
tools
now let me briefly speak switch gears
and kind of talk about some of the
developments and interesting
new opportunities with microbiome
research and data
and before i jump into that i do want to
leave just a couple of minutes if you
have any questions please put your
question into the chat box i'll be able
to see that and address it before i kind
of run on into some of these other
topics that i have uh in my slides
so uh metagenomics and microbiome
is a field that
has both a lot of challenges and a lot
of opportunities
i think the challenges are really
illustrated in the in in the industry uh
by two major factors number one
everyone's probably by now has heard of
you biome a failed company that was uh
kind of popularizes incredible testing
direct to consumer testing uh promising
insights uh you know many other
companies now have taken up that idea
and promised to offer some insight into
what's happening in your gut or what's
happening on your skin
and you can really see that the benefits
direct benefits of such testing are
limited there's really such variation
across individuals that it's difficult
to find some very specific actionable
insights
and
in addition to that i think the trust in
metagenomic sequencing and such
microbiome research has also been uh
kind of questioned by um you know the
ability to kind of offer those tests at
a clinical level uh not clear what
exactly that clinical indicated
indication means and so there's a lot of
questions i think on what can microbiome
can really tell us practically speaking
about the human microbiome but also how
do the methods of analysis and the
sequencing methods allow us to ask those
specific questions in greater detail and
get actual actionable
outcomes and results
so to understand that i think it's
worthwhile to kind of go back and and
see
where did the metagenomics field kind of
develop from
how did it develop into different types
of sequencing methods and where does it
stand today i mean what could the real
opportunity be at the end of the day to
leverage what is available
in the public domain at least
so one of the things that
you know historically
has been a big challenge is
denoising right so one of the
problems with metagenomics data
especially amplicon targeted
metagenomics data is that the data
itself comes from millions and millions
of microbes and we have to
accurately very accurately sequence
enough data from each individual
microorganism to be able to annotate
them using a database and so at every
stage of what i just described there's a
challenge number one there's a challenge
with having enough genomic data to
sequence it accurately at a high enough
depth
number two it is a challenge to amplify
long enough reads to really know the
sequence that will give us a high
confidence in our annotation
number three
the databases for annotation are really
lacking some information at the lower
taxonomy levels and number four at the
end of that we really do not understand
in full detail
how to interpret the differences in
composition be it differences in
taxonomic abundance or differences in
composition in terms of diversity uh and
things like that
so to address this challenge several
different pipelines have been
implemented on the platform and i will
talk briefly today about how those could
be used
so really we have three different
approaches to metagenomic analysis on
the platform and i think they illustrate
some of the challenges and how they're
being addressed in this whole field so
these three include the whole genome
metagenomic analysis where you are
sequencing
long
portions of genomes and one of your goal
goals is to
kind of be able to piece together longer
sequences beyond amplicon and then that
provides you with an opportunity to have
more confidence in your
actual
annotation
number two uh kyme and data two for
amplicon really focus on denoising that
data
removing the inaccurate reads and really
focusing on the reads that only match
their pairs and then to annotate them
with high quality databases where you
can use standard databases like silva
which are available online for free or
proprietary databases that might have
some specific focus and have some
specific annotation
now
in the context of such methods i will
also briefly talk about where this whole
field is going uh beyond the process
data so i'll skip this slide actually
but the point of this slide is that once
you have that data processed and
prepared you are able to understand the
you know scripts that go into each one
of those steps specifically the
downstream analysis where you can find
such methods like fallowseek uh nmds and
others that provide you with these nice
outputs
okay is it possible to modify these
pipelines if required as per the
username yes our team is constantly
working with multiple researchers to
provide them with new pipelines just
recently we've implemented a pipeline
for a single cell
for uh you know different types of
for example spatial single cell all of
these new pipelines come from research
collaborations
so if you have a research project in
mind
we can develop some kind of a
collaboration the result most likely is
going to be that we will have a new
section on the platform dedicated to
that topic where our team will review
multiple methods provide them as a user
friendly in interface but also use them
to actually analyze the data
now in the microbiome space and i'll
kind of go back to my topic
one of the major challenges has been
developing a reference that is
comprehensive enough
and
specialized enough around a particular
topic
so
um
and ls i'll address your comment here in
a second
one of the
original kind of objectives of these
large scale projects was to collect a
baseline and so we see projects like the
human microbiome project british gut
project american project earth
microbiome project and others
really their goal was to establish the
baseline of diversity and so this could
be compared to something like the hap
project in the genomics space where we
try to understand you know what kind of
normal variation exists out there now
obviously the challenge there is the
number and so i think the human
microbiome project is somewhere around
30 000
individuals
really when you think about the
diversity of the microbiome these are
not large numbers and so one of the
challenges is of course that the
diversity is much greater than the
sample size that we have and so even for
the baseline it's difficult to establish
that in a comprehensive way
but as a result of that now some of
those projects have become more
specialized and so here you can see
cancer prevention study for the gut
microbiome
alzheimer's microbiome project nurses
health study micro micro
among nurses and others and so as you
can see from baseline and kind of
general diversity now these projects are
becoming more specialized
as a result
we now have a number of indicators that
have been adopted
for different types of practical
applications when we think of individual
microbiome health lifestyle
food habits etc
and
researchers have started really thinking
about
the microbiome and its establishment
over time
where we can see
a specific microbiome and stereotype for
example
after that is established how is it
affected by the development and adult
microbiome over time
primarily around food
and lifestyle
and i'm talking here about pre-clinical
or kind of healthy type microbiome now
as a result we also see some
sensitivities and pre-clinical
conditions that are a perfect
opportunity for early intervention
and being able to design you know
non-clinical interventions like dieting
fasting you know and other things
prevention of specific lifestyles so
that has become a huge interest because
as we all know treating a chronic
condition or an acute condition is much
more expensive than trying to prevent it
or manage it at the pre-clinical stage
so when we are thinking about microbiome
and the opportunities
let's go and look at some of the things
that we can find in these publicly
available databases and think about how
can that inform you know some of the
specific questions that we might design
or we can think of
and
here this is an example
of a an extraction from the human
microbiome project
uh just the metadata of that project and
what you can see obviously not in a
comprehensive way but you can see here
that uh let's say i have a question you
know
do
is there a microbiome difference
between people who exercise rarely or
regularly you know think again i have 30
000 people available in the human
microbiome project
as a result of that question we were
able to find only about 20 people from
30 000 individuals that have the same
sex the same age the same habits more or
less but only vary by their tendency to
exercise rarely or regularly right so
that is really the challenge when you
think of a question always you need to
go back and see what kind of reference
do i really have
nevertheless some of those conditions
could really be explored in a more
detailed way and as i mentioned some of
them have been established so really the
opportunity and i think the challenge as
well is
finding the right data or collecting the
right data to inform your analysis and
your hypothesis right and where you can
start you can start with the human
microbiome project which is available
for free
now another interesting application of
the human of the microbiome project is
of course
not only the gut microbiome but also
microbiome from other body sites and one
of those interesting ones is the skin
microbiome so in fact a lot of people
are interesting interested
in trying to differentiate between the
effects of uh let's say
factors that we can control as opposed
to factors that are more like genetics
and i think the microbiome sits kind of
in between right so the microbes on the
skin or any surface or gut are
becoming established very strongly even
after depletion with let's say
antibiotics a lot of the
same type of you know composition comes
back and one of the examples here is an
analysis of a paper and some publicly
available data on the comparison between
the
acne and perioral dermatitis another
very interesting application
obviously in the clinical sense this is
becoming a more and more important
component of how we think
not only of the diversity and the types
of microorganisms that are found
but also as we know
they play a major role in the
development of immune responses
intermediate immune responses and
metabolism and so because of their com
you know interven
because of their role in metabolism
treatment becomes a natural next
question how
does the metabolism
uh for uh you know whatever enters their
body affects the actual treatment
efficacy and here you can see a study
uh published in science in 2016 so
really uh
not a recent study that had already
asked the question could we find
microbial signatures
of treatment response
and
i think this
really has a very direct and strong
implication
for our ability to incorporate
microbiome sequencing and microbiome
biomarkers into the actual treatment
development which is a huge industry and
a huge challenge as well
so
now again if you have any specific
questions about metagenomics and
microbiome our team has been working
with the number of interesting projects
at the basic research level as well as
the translational level where we seek to
integrate multiple sources of
information and correlate them with
microbiome signatures and we are going
to be making some uh announcements i
hope in the near future about some
applications that allow to do that to
really make that kind of service
available to individuals so if you have
an interest in microbiome microbiome
biomarkers and metagenomic sequencing i
recommend again reaching out to our team
and also seeing some of the upcoming
opportunities to learn about and and
really talk to us more about your
research ideas
okay so uh briefly i'll take a look at
the chat
all right so excellent thank you for
participating
um you know about the specifics of
metagenomic sequencing i recommend we
have a discussion i think there are some
really interesting developments in the
metagenomic space so ls uh please reach
out to us with that and the question
about cancer genomics we do definitely
have projects on cancer genomics we will
have a whole session dedicated to cancer
genomics in our upcoming symposium i
recommend you join those i won't be
speaking today just because of the time
limitations
okay so now let me speak briefly
about covet sequencing some of the
emerging questions in kovitz sequencing
and surveillance as well as some of the
methods that allow us to ask very
specific questions about the evolution
that is driving differentiation in
strengths
and obviously is of major concern
as the you know public is more kind of
comfortable i think with uh you know
kovit being around and and the question
is you know where do we go from here
where is this whole genomic surveillance
and understanding of uh different clades
going
so just so that we're all on the same
page let's review the basic idea behind
genomic surveillance of code 19 and then
we'll address some of these emerging new
interesting questions that help us
understand kind of the benefit of
continuous surveillance of code 19.
so at the basic level right there is a
large genomic variation
that helps us understand
uh
evolution
and adaptation between different hosts
uh and maybe between different variation
in the host like
immunosuppressed and and you know other
types of people so the basic idea is
that we have some
level of variation if we take a sample
size from the genomic uh you know data
we will see that the amount of variation
changes
by sample whether we take it at a
different stage or if we look at
different portions of the genome and the
idea of that is coming from you know a
virus or a group of viruses infecting an
individual infecting a cell as the
process of replication inside the cell
and evasion of immune responses at the
cellular and the system level
the way that the virus can respond is by
adaptation and changing its genomic
sequence right so as a result if we take
that sample and we sequence it
we will see that we will find many
genomes
and these genomes can be similar to each
other or different from each other right
and that is called genomic diversity
or uh you know in the case of covet 19
we we call these variants right so in
genomics traditionally like cancer
genomics or
germline genomics we talk about variants
as individual snips or individual
positions that are variants in terms of
viruses and cov19 we call
those
whole genomes we call them variants
so
those variants now represent some
genomic diversity
that we can start asking questions about
and so one simple question that we can
ask is
what kinds of variants or what kinds of
positions do we find
that we can characterize right and so
answering that question identifying
specific positions
either in fast q files where we have
deep sequencing or in
assembled genomes can help us for
example categorize different genomes
according to strain or according to
their evolutionary divergence
that kind of analysis is helpful because
we can try to associate clades of
genomic diversity or groups that are
genomically similar to each other with
some phenotype for example a phenotype
associated with the location or type of
people or the
exact kind of phenotypic events that we
can monitor clinically
now in addition to that
we now know that the kind of high-level
genomic analysis of such data
also can help us determine questions
like where did it come from what species
did it come from or how did it evolve
from a particular location to the next
location right so there's also a dynamic
composition to it where we have the
phylogeny and the time component and
together that is called
phylodynamics
as a result of relying on phylodynamic
and further expanding the phylodynamics
to analyze the data that has been
collected
important insights are primarily around
the relationship between the genomic
sequence
and
the way that this genomic sequence
affects the actual protein so because so
much effort and research has been put
into the characterization of the
specific proteins that the virus
produces we can now understand
mutability or the divergence genomic
divergence in the context of proteins
and these proteins of course interact
right the virus proteins interact with
the host proteins and because they
interact with the host proteins we can
now take a look at crystallized
structures of each individual protein
and we can model what actually happens
inside the cell
and as we go through the training in
separate programs that we have like the
kobe 19 training we go through all of
these steps how do we go from sequencing
data to phylodynamic analysis to then
interpretation in the context of
interaction between different protein
structures at the host virus interaction
level now interestingly
that is just part of the story right
as we continue thinking about virus
transmission
or where this whole thing originated
from we need to put in all of the pieces
together to really appreciate what could
drive such diversity in the future
because ultimately
when we understand the different pieces
and how they are connected
we now can think about intervention but
we also can think about the different
processes that affect
the continuous evolution
and as a result i will speak about some
papers that actually speak about how
this is relevant for the future you know
post vaccine and post uh you know uh the
pandemic kind of spreading right it's
already everywhere where does it go from
here
so as you know the previous focus of
such analysis was on different clades
and those clades
have uh increased in number over time
uh the number of mutations seemed to
stabilize at some point
at the delta maybe point and then
started expanding again right and so
one kind of practical outcome that we
take from that and we actually have a
whole workshop coming out uh about that
we can actually just learn how to
process the data
and find the specific positions variants
of concern or something like that that
we want to report on and that is the
focus of that workshop but in addition
to that i want to
point to a paper
that recently came out
that talks about and this is the paper
right here it's called
tracking
cryptic source code two lineages
detected in new york city wastewater
this is an interesting article and i'll
share the link here for anyone who's
interested to kind of go through that
that really leverages
a wastewater sequencing which is
sequencing of again a collection of
different genomes in the wastewater
amplifying them with a specific
amplicon sequencing approach and then
looking for novel mutations that are
emerging and the interesting conclusion
that they arrive at
is that they first of all identify
specific mutations that are not found in
clinical samples
number two they actually took those
mutations and they checked in terms of
binding and and transmission and
replication how do they
replicate in different types of cells
and they um offer several hypotheses on
how these could be driven by non-human
animal reservoir right so what does that
actually mean
that means that you know because we live
with pets because we have rodents
because we have all these animals around
us right we are really starting to see
that the virus
the ability of the virus you know
potentially it came from an animal
reserve war but potentially it continues
to interact with these animal reservoirs
driving evolution how it adapts and how
new uh mutations come out and and of
course we are now interacting with them
again right so this is i think a very
interesting uh you know study that shows
that continuous genomic surveillance
with
sub-consensus analysis
of
data to look for new mutations that are
not yet annotated not just running
through pangolin but looking in depth at
deep sequencing data can help us
understand
how this virus is going to continue to
evolve
so um i think what i did in in the short
time that i had today is i was able to
again go through these three topics as
just a starting point and an
introduction really to some of the
things that we wanted to discuss
these three things were single cell
rna-seq metagenomics and microbiome and
covid's surveillance
i know that there's a lot of training
and opportunities to learn more about
each one of these topics coming up
specifically i want to highlight a a big
event that we're planning called
the omics research symposium where we
have experts from all of these fields
from the fields of cancer genomics and
precision medicine from coveted
surveillance as well as microbiome
analysis and importantly bioinformatics
and data science how can you learn
how can you apply some of these tools
and how you can drive translational
research that actually reaches
you know individuals patients and
populations and makes a difference and
that's really what this workshop is all
about
so again thank you for letting me share
some of these slides i'll pass this back
on to mohit
to kind of talk about some of the
upcoming opportunities
thank you elia for this informative
session i think it was it was very
nicely put together and uh many of the
participants are asking for the video
because i think they would like to
revise and that is all right we will be
sharing the video recording as well uh
now uh about the
lessons intensive part of the session
which just to discuss about the upcoming
opportunities in the context of training
as well as like having these sort of
interacting interactive uh is this sort
of uh
overview session along with hands-on
session and the interactive session that
combines with another
kind
of that combines with asynchronous uh
training as well so it's a blended
training that we are going to be doing
throughout the next month so the topics
that ilya was describing so we have them
uh spaced out one after another so we
are going to start with uh
covet research psych genomic
surveillance of starscope 2
variant of concern and it's reporting
using
uh our script and uh the t-bind for
platform uh analysis and then we will be
after that the next week we will be
doing uh ngs single cell data analysis
and single cell uh rna projects uh that
would be about demonstrating and looking
at some of the projects that are there
as well as some of the research
opportunities that one could think of
through the publicly available data sets
and that would be followed by
machine learning for omix data analysis
which starts uh
the next week
so march 15th
tuesday to uh thursday march 17th where
we will be going through about that how
machine learning is applied and into
these different studies and applications
where we are using these uh
high
high dimensional data to analyze uh to
analyze and get insights from so we will
be using uh different techniques here
and to be learn and also to learn that
how we can apply these techniques into
big data sets and also to utilize some
of the
tools from python and r so it will be
also about coding and as well as
learning about the
transition of data and how to extract
meaningful information that will be
followed by um
the
uh
the uh question that we answered about
cancer genomics and where we will be
covering a detailed analysis using the
rewind for platform to analyze cancer
mutations uh using this uh genomic data
and to sum it up like it will be
to
discuss about also like the training and
also the research and what we are doing
uh with our omics logic curriculums
we will be discussing uh that in our
faculty and mentor workshop where that
will be an opportunity for
faculty especially to integrate some of
these
some of these
curriculums such as introduction to
bioinformatics data science and machine
learning into uh into their
teaching or into their uh
into the projects so uh and obviously we
discussed about the
omics logic research symposium that
would be towards the end of uh end of
the end of march where we will have
guests from uh almost all around the all
around the world it's a bi-annual
symposium uh that we conduct it will
involve uh about all the uh you know uh
outcomes that come from different types
of analysis that we go through from
different uh
different
training programs as well as research
internships and research fellowships as
well as as research projects that we are
doing
so um
about the dates and all the
registrations uh
i'll share with you uh so if you can see
my screen
uh we have
the registrations available
which is shared by our team here in the
chat for genomic surveillance and then
we have the sas group
then we have the
single cell and that would be followed
by machine learning and then
the other programs along with that we
have some expert sessions coming up uh
which would be from our iomix club that
would be uh also to address some of the
important questions so today we also
discussed about
structure biology so how do we integrate
structure biology from sequence to
structure to function so we'll be
discussing that in our next event which
is on 25th february 7 30 pm so you can
also register for this if you're
interested to learn about structure
biology and its application and research
project designing uh so in our other
in the in the in the workshop that we
were discussing all about uh today which
is the genomic surveillance of sasko2
and varian variant of concern reporting
so here we will have sessions starting
from first march so we will start from
the very basic understanding of about
data collection so how this data is
collected what what is the technology
behind this data for those you know
principle investigators or for those
research scientists who are starting
with their career or who are thinking
about these projects or grants can think
about uh research ideas uh starting from
data collection starting from utilizing
uh understanding about the known case
studies so this is something that we are
planning to do uh
in our workshop starting from an uh from
an expert session so in this expert
session we will cover uh those aspects
followed by that we will be trans uh we
will be moving to
more of a technical part where we will
be analyzing data in respect of a
research project so we'll be utilizing
the tbi info platform where we'll be
using uh specific algorithms and
databases and data sets to uh to analyze
viral genomes so so that everyone gets
an overview and obviously these sessions
are also designed based on the
level of expertise that is required for
anyone to get or learn about these so
these introductory sessions on day one
will be beginner level sessions and uh
followed by uh a an asynchronous session
which is uh which is on day two but the
third session on on day one so we've
after having both uh the sessions at uh
8 am and 9 am we will have the third
session at 10 am cest where we will be
discussing starting to discuss about the
nature of emerging variants many of
those which we discussed in today
today's webinar but in much more depth
and in the context with the data set
that we are uh analyzing at that point
of time using the tbi info platform so
after doing uh all of those sessions on
day one uh as we are also like exploring
as a participants you will be also
exploring many of those who join uh
these workshops will be exploring so we
will
we have prepared a lot of resources for
you to utilize and those resources are
uh something that you will have an
opportunity to cover on day two which is
to go through uh and to do these
hands-on using the t-band platform using
the code playground that all of those
that will be described in day one and
which will give you an idea to how to go
and go through all of this through our
or our online support
so this is the plan for the day two
where you will be able to uh learn this
from a basic uh to an advanced level
based on your own uh level of expertise
so followed by that day three is more
research oriented where we will be
actually working on these
on this uh data sets to look at
different types of uh uh
like it is it from clinical experiments
sequencing data environmental sequencing
data here we will be discussing about
the case studies that we have already
worked on and also uh come up with all
of these
different reporting systems and also
different uh outcomes that we have found
so from these different analysis uh so
as we have already discussed this so we
will from we will be trans uh moving
from one session to another that
actually uh is related to one another
but also at the same time these type of
data analysis are indeed could be
independently done and uh if you have
like
if you don't have time for
for the entire day you can join one of
these sessions and uh interact with us
during the workshop as well as get
recording for the entire uh entire
workshop once you are once it is over
and you can practice it on your own for
one month or henceforth those recordings
are always available
so uh that's the uh so it it will
followed by the last session that we
have uh on march 3rd which will be to
generate the report and utilizing r and
looking at and analyzing that and
relating it with the research question
so that that would be uh the sars scope
2 plan and the infectious disease those
who are interested in infectious disease
research and especially in our school
too could uh join that workshop with us
and learn from uh one of some of our
experts from industry as well as from
academy
followed by that we have a psionic
session it's an uh free
data science and student club and
bioinformatics student club that i
invite many of you to join because here
it's a rich community of
the students who are organizing these
events for this for their own colleges
for their own uh universities helping
other students to learn about
data science omixological resources and
bioinformatics uh
tools and techniques and courses that
are available uh through omixlogic
uh so followed by that as i said we have
on 8th to 10th march the single cell
single cell analysis single cell
transcriptomics data analysis
workshops so here we will be learning
about uh some of the
important uh
pathways usually so uh usually what we
do is that we start with and broad
overview of single cell transcriptomics
uh data analysis and uh the applications
so looking from a perspective of where
this is to and where this could be
applied to there are a lot of questions
that many uh faculty and many students
ask
which which is to understand that actual
application and if it is related or if
it could be integrated into their
research idea so that uh that overview
is something that we start with and we
also uh discuss about different ways to
get uh to work on single cell so is it
it could be through training training of
of a student it could be through
research service or it could be through
um
collaborations so that's what we are
discussing starting with the day one and
that would be followed by a project
example or hands-on that would uh where
we will be discussing about the
downstream analysis that we discussed uh
with dr raghavendran who is one of our
mentors
and is here in today's meeting as well
so uh again the format uh helps you
learn about all of that all of this so
whatever you learn on the on day one you
get to learn uh all of this through uh
available video recordings so
along with this we will be providing you
expert recorded video recording on day
two where we will be also providing you
uh the
courses and tutorials that we covered
and the hands-on assignments on divine
for platform that gives you like a real
experience of uh completing some of the
things that we discussed and that could
be relevant to your research or that
what that something that you could be
hoping to do maybe in in in the upcoming
days in the future or as a postdoctoral
fellow or as a as a faculty
so
um these are some of the uh um
sorry
so this is the plan for day two and
after that we have day three where we
have an expert talk to summarize and
understand where we are with uh single
cell uh transcriptomics and its
application in clinic followed by that
we will be moving to
machine learning and data science so uh
how do we
after understanding uh the data
from preprocessing data to cleaning the
data
now we are trying to integrating and
analyzing the data using machine
learning methods and uh
in this short workshop which is for from
15th of march to 17th of march we will
cover important topics uh which are
actually applied in many projects that
we do and many student projects that
comes across so many of our research
fellows who will be submitting their
posters and uh who will be submitting
their articles
in journals
will be
will be benefiting from these sessions
where they could learn about
dimensionality reduction and clustering
techniques that
is used for describing many of those
research analysis results that we use in
our poster presentation in our reports
in our presentations and as well as in
the preprints and publications so that
that's the focus of uh the workshop is
to first go go about it different types
of data types that we discussed using
the tbi info platform and then
apply machine learning techniques and
explore the data and uh
to look at the dimensionality of the
data and all of
what we can understand from the
uh from the uh from both uh
exploratory analysis and then learning
from the
online materials that we have prepared
for especially for data science and
machine learning workshop so this is uh
more about coding so here we have r and
python where you will be able to
replicate some of the things that we
that we practice from the gui as well as
you know do downstream analysis and
especially when we are talking about uh
obtaining great uh graphical results
using uh
using different types of methods uh such
as you know
uh uh using uh
uh
predictive analysis as well as
classification so first we will learn
about uh predictive and uh first we will
learn about you know uh dimensional
reduction and clustering and then we are
learning about predictive analysis and
in this entire workshop you will be also
getting these tutorials
like r for omics bioinformatics here you
will learn about different uh
different
sessions that we take and go through
these different
analysis and steps
so
the last session is also to get you
through rn python and to get you through
and to learn about how to do pcas and
how to use them using how to build uh
those using r and python and then it
would be about the classification that
would be the last session on march 17th
to learn about supervised machine
learning and uh then to happen broad
over getting great good overview about
how we apply machine learning for next
generation sequencing data and what kind
of um
graphical
inputs that we can
get to get a good uh research outcome
from these sort of analysis or to get
some uh under deeper understanding from
this analysis and uh followed by that
march 22nd we have that cancer mutation
genomic session where we will be looking
at the tools for genomic data analysis
to interrogate genomic variations for
cancer studies and to perform so and to
look at the somatic and germline
variant detection driver and passenger
mutations copy number variation as well
as subclonal deconvolution so this is
something that is integrated in the
t-band for platform where
i think many who are working on oncology
who are working on cancer uh cancer
genomics or are interested in working in
different types of because a lot of data
is available on public repositories
which
which is uh which is widely used by
many scientists so followed by that the
last session the last workshop before
the symposium is on uh on curriculum
development so we have our uh
uh
university partners whom we are working
with and we where we have these
curriculums
[Music]
where these curriculums
are integrated
for students to go through these
specific trainings like learning about
different types of formix technologies
as well as integrating them into uh
into the into the curriculum so that uh
the student learn about the
project-based learning as well as uh the
basics are covered through their uh
curriculum uh
with within the university so uh we
already have many of these uh
curriculums that we wanted to showcase
and uh we would like to
discuss with uh many of you who are
interested
so um that is uh the
uh the plan for march and we are hoping
that many of you could make it to some
of these sessions and join us uh for to
learn with us and also to let us know
about what do you feel about it and uh
how can you be a part of many of these
research projects that we are doing
which are based through this project
based learning through these exploration
of data uh which is available on public
which is available on public
repositories as well as uh the data that
many of you are generating and could be
supported through our expertise through
our tools that we discussed today and
through our collaborations uh that we
are putting up together uh by
by getting all of us together and
getting us to a platform where we can
discuss science and actually
also do signs by using all of those
resources that we discussed today so
that's uh that's what we i wanted to do
to tell you in my part of the
presentation but let me ask my team to
share
some of these uh
links where you'll find all this
information about the events and uh also
uh uh
also if you are interested to reach uh
interested in reaching out to us
for any sort of you know research
question any sort of um
any sort of training related question or
career guidance
that then please feel free to reach out
to us through
through email or
or uh filling up some of these forms
that are present that are available in
these uh
in these links that uh are being shared
so we have the research symposium
workshops listed as just we have shared
and also the research symposium so many
of you
uh could
join the research symposium and showcase
your poster and get an opportunity to
get real feedback from some of the
domain experts uh
who are who will be
uh who will be joining this symposium so
um as this uh this is the page that you
can see on my screen uh so you can
register it's a free event and i'm
hoping that many of you who would have
benefited from today's session would
encourage others also and please
feel free to share this link with your
contacts so that many of the students or
interested
interested faculty can benefit from
these uh these talks from these experts
from industry scientists research
scientists ex and also
specialization experts
so we will have collaborators from a lot
of universities uh talking about their
programs and as well as industry experts
from uh from pharmaceuticals and
biotechnology
and agriculture and henceforth so we'll
be looking forward for your
participation and we'll be looking
forward to see you uh in march uh for
our events it was great meeting you all
and
i'll surely be looking if there are any
questions that i can help answer
and if you're a faculty yes many of
these workshops are available uh for
free
and uh most of them are for free a few
of them are as they are training
and you require
specific t buyer info access then there
is a
there is a
registration fee for the certification
and debian for access but most of the
sessions are free for you to
join
and learn from especially the research
symposium
so again thank you all for joining
today's session it was great meeting to
you all and it was great uh
to see that many of you asked actually
many questions i'm hoping for you to ask
more questions in the next next time
then we meet and and hope to see you
many of you in the workshop uh where we
will have more opportunity to discuss
one-on-one
you